[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to
GameSpot's year-in-review 2017 we here
are going to talk about Nintendo pretty
banner year I'd say I'm like my heart a
year with Pete Brown you took the words
right out of my mouth callyblackie me as
well
March 3rd in tennis which came out so
many good things to say well get into
the negatives cuz there are a few but in
general breath of the wild March 3rd on
Nintendo switch what could you say about
that launch day Peter Brown it was crazy
it was a bit it was super important I
mean it's sort of you know set the pace
or at least Li you know raise the bar
for what people expect from Nintendo and
daresay they've done a pretty good job
of keeping up with that you know they
haven't necessarily found as much
success with every game after zelda but
they did the zelda but god what a way to
jumpstart that system yeah we were
talking about yesterday kelly it was
kind of like a redemptive year for them
right like i come back home after those
wii u years when it didn't seem like
they had an identity or confidence it
feels like the switch was where they
wanted to be five years ago but like to
the tenth degree yeah absolutely in that
launch day i I didn't pre-order a switch
I felt a little burned by the Wii U I
was an early adopter and then when I saw
Zelda in the office I bought some
buddies like somebody bought to you and
I bought it off of them cuz I knew I had
to play it and I couldn't put it down
for two months I mean that was just such
a Nintendo Redemption arc for me like I
really felt like I I needed to have my
faith reinstalled and and that was the
first step I think in doing that for me
yeah they have a traditional III press
conference but they did have the direct
that kind of got a good rhythm going
with these new tender directs where
they're releasing these news and Reggie
got up on stage and did one of his
monologues is he's one to do
he would you think about the Nintendo
Direct I'll everything they showed
between Metroid Prime 4 and then kind of
a hid the Metroid Samus Returns
announcement in the livestream after but
in general what was it like yeah I'm not
a huge fan of these live streams after
at least from our position you know as
someone who's trying to cover the news
but I mean Metroid Prime for was the
thing that I was waiting for so that
really just dominated
my takeaway really and we didn't see
anything except for a logo I think we
know that retro studios the team that
made the previous games is not working
on this one so I'm very curious about
where it's headed but to give me two
Metroid games in one you know sitting
that was all I need you yeah I mean the
Metroid Prime four was just the teaser
obviously but then we look at Metroid
Samus Returns they show like a whole
gameplay demo it shut it off and of
course we played that game in September
and people have been saying when's 2d
Metroid gonna come back didn't talk
about Sam's returns enough in general as
like game fans but Khalid you get that
she has to play it do you think it was
the comeback for Metroid as well I
played a little bit and I'm not super
well versed in Metroid admittedly but
from hearing Peter talk about it and
hearing people who who really are big
Metroid fans sort of waiting for a 2d
Metroid to come back it seemed very
encouraging especially because Nintendo
kind of loosened the reins and let a
third-party developer step in we're
taking every steam tackle that was
really encouraging and that's another
trend we've been saying from intended us
here is is kind of loosening the grip on
their properties and let entrusting
third parties to to come in and import
things or help with development and
stuff like that and then that part was
also encouraging to me and also
vice-versa third parties are trusting
Nintendo now I mean Bethesda was one of
the first ones to swear them off back in
2015 I think they were saying like the
Wii U is not worth optimizing our games
or it's just not the audience isn't
there but of course now you have
Wolfenstein 2 coming out next year you
have doom that's out on the switch you
have Skyrim one of their biggest the
biggest games of all time that just
keeps coming out on every platform Pete
are you encouraged by the way that third
parties are kind of jumping on this Mike
Rotundo bandwagon big and small honestly
yeah like I'm seeing you know obviously
the games you mentioned a lot of great
games from any studio is coming it's you
know one of the biggest problems we use
that it just didn't have enough games
the exclusives it had were great and
that is also true for switch but now
it's great to also you know have those
games you might have played elsewhere
also available in the system because
it's a wonderful convertible system you
can play on the go or a new TV even it
goes without saying at this point but
that's a huge deal I can totally change
the way that I engage with some of these
games so very encouraged by the support
across the board yeah and jumping off of
that the Wii U like you you do have like
captain toad was one of my favorite Wii
U games but that was just like a system
to play Nintendo
party games on and then that was never
my system of choice for anything else
whereas the switch you know I think it's
talking to somebody yesterday about you
know sonic mania is a game that came out
on multiple platforms for a lot of
people switch was the platform of choice
yeah for that game and so it's really
cool to see third-party games be like
it's switch to be a destination for
those games rather than I guess I'll
play Zelda on my Nintendo system and
that's all I use it for it and then it
collects dust kind of thing yeah I mean
Nintendo came out of the hole that we
feel like they're in with you and just
lent Mario to Ubisoft from Mario plus
rabbit's Kingdom battle the game was a
big surprise and I think a lot of people
in the office here liked it but in
general it seems like Nintendo was also
porting a lot of things to the switch
stardew valley lovers in a dangerous
space-time axiom verge all came out
within that one week B does that
encourage you to like have a switch even
more so yeah like I just Kali's point
it's just like it's my favorite place to
play games right now seeing influx of
stuff that we've already received and
knowing what's on the horizon I can't
help but be excited about that Super
Nintendo classic came out this year as
well and we were worried because they
initially said it's gonna cease
production into 2017 and then they ended
up saying oh the demands there which
they seem to be surprised but there's
there's money to be made
no and then they announced they're gonna
make it next year they also have that in
Tendo classes we could come back next
summer yeah what do you think about
Nintendo supposedly you know listening
more to fans of those platforms now
Kelly oh it's it's nice to see a
Nintendo not doing only what we thought
like with amiibo being like that false
demand like oh restrict the supply of
amiibo and then there'll be more you
know people be more enticed to buy them
it almost feels like an accident after
this where they're like oh people want
to buy the SNES cost literally what they
say yeah oops like it just seems like
it's nice to me to to have more faith
that they're they know what they're
doing with that sort of thing and also
just as somebody who wants an SNES
classic and didn't want to go on eBay
and pay a thousand dollars for one I'm
personally very happy about that and
just the idea that Nintendo is kind of
like okay we're we're back and we're
kind of gonna take more control over
what we're doing and be more confident I
guess I feels like a nintendo of old I
mean there was a point in time when
Nintendo was just you know such a you
know for the fans a very friendly
company to to look up to right I mean
you had Nintendo Power magazine which
all types of purses was like for
advertising but it was done in such a
way that actually compelled people to to
think about these games on a more
regular basis because they were getting
lots of information lots of
entertainment because Nintendo
sanctioned that stuff right they had
that access to the company in a way that
that other companies didn't allow and
four years in Tendo just didn't do what
people were asking for
so on top of the nostalgia stuff on top
of Metroid it's just it's great yeah and
I do want to talk about some of that
more like negative things especially
surrounding the switch still not a great
voice chat especially earlier in the
year yeah and and it doesn't have right
like so then you're playing splatoon too
earlier in the year you had to use the
discord or if you had there actually the
app or whatever that would shut off if
your phone went Blacky yeah they did
update it so it won't shut off if your
phone screen turns like I don't getting
there so you know but the the fact that
they have I mean to your point about
them listening to fans more I I'm a
little more encouraged that that is
something they'll Bend on but it does
feel like there's a couple quality of
life things like voice chat like cloud
saves there wasn't you know like
Nintendo didn't have or the switch
didn't have save transfer in the
beginning and they had to add that retro
actively that kind of stuff it's like
okay I feel like you you're still a
little bit mired in some Nintendo isms
the lack of you know gamertag type
things you have to search through friend
code stuff like that so maybe they'll
they'll they'll continue this trend of
listening to fans but that has been
rather annoying
it was super annoying with splatoon and
I think that's a game that that could
have been a great you know beta test
essentially for voice chat on intended
system and and that was a big miss for
me yeah that game I mean even back with
that October update when they said you
could transfer say if I'll still delete
some off the home console right you
can't just copy them you're like
actually kind of moving them the way
that three
safe transfer works it's right it's not
a very sophisticated system so you have
three DS fire mode echos again metroid
sandwich returns as always great entries
to that platforms library to TS excel
came out this year what you think about
Nintendo's handheld support you think
it's just pretty much the same story
they're always gonna support it's gonna
do well and the switches handheld isn't
that sure yeah I mean I think they're
there they've got their feet in two
different you know categories with
switch as far as 30s is concerned I
wouldn't be surprised to see the number
of games shrink they have said that
they're gonna keep supporting it that
it's not a dead platform to them switch
is not replacing it
I personally don't necessarily buy that
I'm not really sure that they're gonna
be seeing games made for 3ds when they
could be made on switch and they could
sell you know potentially a lot more but
again switches or 3d s is still really
popular so it remains to be seen but I
don't know what the next great 3d asking
this yeah it's I think the game's
definitely have been dwindling for 3ds
this year and that's one of the things I
have noticed and of course that
libraries already so robust that I'm not
looking for you know like a ton of big
standout games like we've seen on switch
that's where I want them to put their
focus right like I would want to have
those that install base of games but it
I mean having the the 2d s XL is like
here's a cheaper alternative kind of
like our our final version of the
clamshell 2d s design and that's that's
nice I mean it's it I think it's a
really good piece of hardware um so it's
nice to see them still continuing that
to support it even if it's not kind of
the focus if you spend money on a
Nintendo Nintendo handheld you know
you're gonna get your money's worth
yeah in general yeah and generally
probably also no it's a really great
year when we haven't even talked about
the fact that on October 27th they
released like the one of the better 3d
Mario platformers or platformers in
general P you've liked tomorrow a lot
one of our three pens this year that we
gave out yeah it's uh it's it's Mario as
we know but also a new type of Mario and
you know it kind of falls in line with
Zelda in that way and with Nintendo sort
of taking a little bit of risk but still
giving us again like you know what we
want but even things we didn't know what
wanted it it's it's crazy that there's
so much to talk about that we actually
get tomorrow yeah yeah yeah there that's
the best thing about this year is like
and to end it I mean I know the years
not quite over and it wasn't over an
October 27th but I'm still playing Mario
and that game is just so full of joy in
a time where I think a lot of us really
need that boost and that is something
that that maybe I couldn't identify that
I wanted and not maybe what I was
expecting to get out of Mario is this
like I'm still collecting moons I'm
really happy to have that through the
end of this year be overall 2017 for
Nintendo do you think a fantastic year I
mean I can't think of you know any other
year that I've been as happy to be a
Nintendo fan you know whatever you want
to call it and out of all the three big
players like I think they had the best
year anymore okay what about you yeah I
agree this is the year I needed from
Nintendo to reinvigorate my my love of
what they do and generally make me
believe that Nintendo is is not stuck in
ideas that don't work and stuck in the
past and really interested in moving
forward with the things that intended it
was best and we've really seen that this
year with Zelda and Mario especially and
this which is my favorite place to play
games
yeah Nintendo no longer the perennial
underdog you might say and as for Sony
and Microsoft and then also PC and
Virtual Reality we will be talking about
all five here in game spots 2017 you're
in review so stay tuned for those we'll
see you then
[Music]
you
[Music]